hey you guys
movie retrospective time once again this
one was
uh actually in the patreon poll that uh
you vote on the movies you know what i
mean this one and battle royale were
actually tied
so i had to flip a coin to figure out
which one we were doing we'll do battle
royale at some point as well
because i know a lot of people wanted to
see us do that one but today we're going
to talk about
a hammer film yeah this one's something
else i like this one
i would love this [ __ ]
what's it called vampire vampire lover
vampire lover it's a hammer horror film
it's the british boob fest and it's
[ __ ] greatest it is
boobalicious yeah this is like late it's
a boobapalooza
actresses hot european actresses just
cute as [ __ ] late 60s looking early 70s
the hair hairdos and everything just
lessen out
trying to get at each other damn here
you think a porn move is going to break
out at any moment
and it's like classy and [ __ ] it looks
good
yeah it's like but this i think is one
of the
most shameless [ __ ] shameless um
but not i'm not saying that in a bad way
because i like this movie i think it's
super fun
yeah i mean it's not quite a russ myers
film
you know what i mean the british didn't
take it that far you know with their
their their boob fix [ __ ] boob fixation
you know
it didn't take as far as [ __ ] you
know russ meyers but
pretty close pretty close like i said
it's just this whole thing is just
better written than a rust monitor
nudity and stuff like that well that's
because it's a literary adventure yeah
yeah it's carmilla basically it is yeah
yeah well it actually it's a it's a
pretty faithful adaptation like you
wouldn't think that they
restructured it a little bit from the
original story yeah but yeah so
this one uh vampire lovers came out in
1970
now this was the first of what would
later come to be called the karnstein
trilogy
uh we did one of the other movies twins
of evil i think that was the
third one maybe that came out in like
yeah like i said that's like down blast
the movie
this one was actually down blouse the
epic
this one is actually like way more
explicit than that
so so yes lesbianic as hell it is but
the thing about it
is that so it's um so it's an adaptation
of uh sheridan lefinews uh novella
carmilla
which uh for anybody that doesn't know
actually came out in 1872 i think it was
and it that was 26 years before dracula
um and so the thing about it is that
they made this movie
and you know they had to uh send the
script i guess to like the sensors or
whatever
and the sensors were like what you can't
like do this you can't put all this
lesbian stuff in there but
bite each other on it well they got it
they got it all in there because they
said hey
it's in the original source material
which it is
it's a literary adaptation so they were
allowed to get away with it and get away
with it they did
yeah it's funny man people
think all this lgbt stuff is new that
[ __ ] goes way
back way back yeah the interesting thing
about it i mean it's not
in the original story i mean and like i
said
as as boobalicious as this is it is
actually a very faithful adaptation of
the book at least from what i can
remember of it
um as i said i think it's like
restructured in the sense that
they kind of do it more in the story
like part of the [ __ ] like
um with the the one kernel or whatever
that's played by peter cushing in the
movie
that was um like it came at the end but
it was like a flashback
so they did they structured the movie
like more in a kind of linear fashion
because i feel like the story itself is
kind of like somebody talking and then
they're talking about flashbacks about
other
iterations of carmilla like showing up
in other people's lives and [ __ ] like
that but it's
it retains the spirit of that story you
know what i'm saying
so basically you got peter cushing gets
pretty high billing on this
but he's like i don't i don't want to
say he's barely in it
but he's not in it as much as you might
think that he's gonna be
you know what i'm saying yeah so he's a
little bit underused i feel like which
is kind of a shame
but you do get the lovely
and again boobtacular ingrid pitt
yeah she's fantastic in this as like the
main
batty carmilla uh they call her my
miracala they call her many other days
the one that she was going after was
even more stacked though
and she's like which one she went after
her old little blonde
she's just cute as [ __ ] i mean she looks
like she's drawn by walt disney with a
damn profile
she had big old eyes yeah yeah huge
[ __ ] eyes what's a lesbian yeah she
doesn't know what the [ __ ] it is
she doesn't say that about you i'm gonna
get you and
and she carmela tricks her into taking
her
what is her name carmilla the vampire
yeah it is right because
that was not really clear they didn't
say it to me well it's because
um she's not actually known as carmilla
also like the third iteration of the
story because
they're trying to show that this is the
same woman and she's lived for centuries
and centuries but she goes by different
names but it's always like an anagram
program
right she tricks this young girl into
taking her [ __ ] clothes off and it's
like
bam she was just putting
putting barbara eden to shame that's
[ __ ] she was wow that's high praise
yeah because we know how much tom loves
barbara eden
one of the prettiest women ever built
ever built
in the factory it could be natural but
you know people forget that now they had
they had silicone infusion back then
they didn't have implants well sometimes
i think they did
they usually just infuse the a person
with silicone
a lot of you you should write a book
about breast technology breast
technology
technology yeah yeah yeah they have
people
well they had you would be very i was
living in brazil as a kid you know what
i mean like and all the favela girls
were [ __ ] doing
silicone infusion yeah with with
commercial grade silicone not medical
grades so you know
you don't know what's living in that
[ __ ] they just put it in a pot and
[ __ ] heat it up
you know then try to kill as much
bacteria as they could in it put it in
an iv bag and just stick that needle
wherever they wanted it just drip it in
there until it was done
yep yeah and which sounds crazy as [ __ ]
i'm getting back on [ __ ] boobs
i was gonna say anything anytime we talk
about a movie like this he goes off i
heard
a boob i was just listening to a
discussion of
cosmetic surgeons that [ __ ] said that
it would probably make that it's safer
probably just go back to that
well i don't know it was only just
because there was some
there were some women that had allergic
reactions to it but it was pretty
uncommon
that they seem to have more problems
with do the way they do it now with
this it's still silicone against you it
doesn't matter
he gets all distracted all distracted
but
i think she was i don't know i i kind of
doubt i kind of doubt the these
i kind of doubt that blob was natural
way she was laying down
maybe again it's hard to tell it's hard
you know
but it might have just been that she was
young and they were still like kind of
perky maybe but
she's genetically brought blessed i mean
they're out there some people they're
out there but
yeah yeah so basically like i said this
is part of the this is the first movie
the karnstein trilogy which
you know are this one's really the only
one that's a straight-up adaptation of
carmilla the other ones are just kind of
like tangentially related there's
another one called lust for a vampire
that was the second one i think and that
came out in 1971 which
um i think shutter just added it so i
think shutter's got all three of them
now now that i'm
thinking about it um and then which i
don't think i've seen that one and then
um you know twins of evil which also
came out and they 71 is the third one
and we reviewed that one a little while
back because like i said shutter added
that one
so basically the story of it is there's
this uh country called styria which
is that this the country or the region
because
i think it's supposed to be in austria
somewhere like the austrian empire or
something
and this is supposed to be like the
early 19th century same time that the um
you know about the same time that the
novel came out or a little bit later
and uh so you get this kind of thing
where there's a dude
and his name is what's what's his name
like hartog or something like that
i couldn't keep eating the name and they
do like a pre like a little bit of a
preview
where this dude is younger and he sees
this woman that's like coming out of the
grave and she like has her shroud on and
she's like all
moving around and everything like that
and then she he like takes her shroud
because i guess
this is something and i don't remember
if this is in the original story or not
because it's been a while since i've
read it
but there is some lore in this that if
you
take the vampire shroud like while
they're outside the grave and then like
they can't
get back in the grave for some reason
because they need the shroud
i guess it's kind of like a grave dirt
type of thing like in dracula
except it's shroud so he takes the
shroud
the vampire comes after him she takes
like the shroud off and she's like super
hot and then he cuts her head off so
that's kind of like a prequel like
that's something that happened like a
long time ago
and then you come into this thing where
because like i said this is a
like sort of like three parts it's like
three different iterations
of carmilla the same woman um you know
living
all of these decades and like feasting
on various people so they're kind of
going from one family to another like
from one victim to another
and they don't realize that this is all
the same person
so you basically get the next
thing that happens is you have um
general spielsdorf
who is played by peter cushing and
they're at this like
they're having this big like ball or
whatever and then this
woman shows up with her daughter
named marcela who was ingrid pitt like
looking all hat in her like red dress
and whatever
and you know so it happens that it's
like oh coincidentally she's like oh i
just had this really bad emergency like
somewhere else
so can you guys i just need to leave my
daughter here for a little while can you
guys just like look after her
um and peter cushing's all like can do
because you know she's super hot and
everything peter cushion was looking
[ __ ]
fan looking all [ __ ] fantastic in his
1700s attire
that old no molar no back teeth having
[ __ ] peter cushing can say
i wish i had them damn cheekbones i do
too the thing is is it dude didn't weigh
anything if you looked at him looked
like he was on the point brink of
starvation
there's something kind of sexy about
that though he looked weak to me though
well it depends on the person
like some people can like wear it well
and i think that he like wore
it really well he was real skinny well
yeah but that was that was his whole
thing though that was his whole look
yeah
it was awesome
yeah yeah that's a good star wars too
that's what i mean that shit's like
[ __ ]
otherworldly like those cheekbones that
he had yeah
nobody else i can't even think of
anybody else i think there was some kind
of issue there though
well maybe yeah he's just like yes that
dude that dude weighed 125 pounds
maybe yeah well yeah but like i said hey
he was a successful actor so
what do you mean i i have a feeling he
didn't have any back teeth though maybe
not
yeah although that might just be an
urban legend like
cher getting her ribs removed and [ __ ]
like that which is not the case
i think he was skinny yeah i had all my
back teeth for me
i don't think that would work even i
don't think that would work because it
would just like make it
make [ __ ] up come on just let me say
[ __ ] it's just saying [ __ ] just
to say it yeah i say whatever comes out
of my mouth
can i i need to write that down that's
another shirt i say whatever comes out
of my mouth
yesterday yesterday i'm writing that
down okay
because i want to make a t-shirt out of
that see whatever comes out of my mouth
yeah yeah yesterday i i pronounced uh i
pronounced
arthur scopenhauer's name is scopenhauer
and a guy said it he lost brain cells
some people call it schopenhauer i guess
you can call himself an hour
i always thought in that language i
thought ch was like a hard ch
i thought so too you know i don't really
care i mean if he wants me to change my
pronunciation
he's have to come and whip my ass you
beat my ass uh i'll let you i'll change
my pronunciation
but if i beat your ass i'm gonna hit i'm
gonna go straight animal on you
uh-oh ain't that something that's quite
quite the odds huh
uh yeah sure i'll change my
pronunciation or i get to [ __ ] you
yeah okay that's like [ __ ] god's
covenant with israel
you will do this
that's my covenant i'm just really not
all that invested in the pronunciation
of that paper
whatever yeah either
i thought it was too but like i said
it's you know it's not my native
language so i'm not uh
i'm not real sure but yeah i heard it so
basically
uh you know this ingrid pitt gets left
i'm just gonna call her that because she
has like three different names
throughout the movie
she gets left with this family and she
immediately like gets
all into uh peter cushing's niece
laura now laura starts having these
nightmares now one of the best things
about this movie i really really like
like the
they're very brief but like i like the
nightmare uh
you know sequences that they have
because they do them like in black and
white
and it's almost kind of like surrealist
like they have like these really weird
like close-ups of like eyes and like you
know anger pit's eyes and then like
sort of this weird i don't know it's
just like this whole weird thing that
they have going and i
and i dig it but she starts having like
laura starts having all these nightmares
about a humongous cat
coming into her room and like biting her
on the boob
now like i said you can say like hammer
films is like oh you know biting around
the boob or whatever but that isn't the
original story and the big cat thing is
in the original story too because like i
said this is a pretty faithful that
makes
sense like a vampire is going to
manifest itself to like its spirit totem
dragon it was like bats and wolves with
this with this hottie it's a [ __ ] cat
yeah cause she's like a predator like a
saber-toothed tiger i understand
she was beating his dude's ass in the
movie yeah and she was like
man biting on the tip well yeah good
body why
i mean why do you think that this movie
is so beloved
this is a huge cult classic yeah she's
putting the moves on men and women when
she put them on the men it was so she'd
get advantage of and kill him
[ __ ] awesome yeah i mean it seemed
like she was mostly the thing about this
and i was watching another
uh review of this it might have been
grumpy andrew's house of [ __ ] i like
him he's a
british fella but um he was talking
about
how ingrid pitts character in this and
in the the novella as well
i feel like she's almost i mean she
still looks like she's a monster
because she's like going after these
young girls and like killing them like
draining their life force and [ __ ]
but she almost comes across as like a
little bit sympathetic because
it's almost like she wants them to love
her
and she wants like a companion yeah
but she's like cursed so it's almost
kind of like she's like miriam blaylock
in
the hunger where it's like she really
she wants somebody that's going to stay
with her forever but it doesn't work out
and so but she doesn't have any other
way of going about things because she's
like cursed to like drink blood because
she's a vampire and [ __ ]
so it's like so she's a lot more
interesting
and complex i guess than just a straight
up monster that just kills people
because she's got to drink blood because
she seems to actually
have feelings for these girls that she's
draining yeah you could see
you can see where um anne rice got a lot
of her ideas for well she has said that
interview with the vampire was
was influenced a great deal by carmilla
yeah
because it's that same it's that same
dynamic yeah
that uh it's a good flick i mean a lot
of a lot of subsequent vampire uh
lore was influenced by carmilla which is
really weird because
even though it came out like a quarter
century before dracula
and i guess it's better known now but i
mean dracula is like way way way better
known
but the thing about it is that bram
stoker was influenced by carmilla as
well
because he read like pretty much all the
vampire lore and vampire [ __ ] that he
it's a similar kind of story it is uh i
can understand why dracula made you know
made the big time first
you really couldn't tell a story like
this back in the early 1900s you know in
a film
you'd get in a lot of trouble you could
do it because the black cat had weird
elements of sexuality in it and
necrophilia and
female slavery you know white slavery
and stuff was in it but
it didn't really make any references to
lesbianism and [ __ ] it was kind of
showing that
although you could say well she wasn't
really lesbian because she wasn't a
human she was a monster
but maybe that's kind of why they
skirted it right but i do feel like i
mean the thing about it is that the
original novella which like i said came
out in 1872
was pretty open about the lesbian i
don't think they used that word or
anything like that but the way
i mean they did talk about carmilla
being like
romantically interested in like her
victims which were almost all female
she does kill some some dudes but that's
usually just to get them out of the way
this might be a cleaned up version of
[ __ ] countess bathory
yeah maybe the guy had heard of countess
bathroom well yeah
definitely because i'm gonna change that
around you know make her [ __ ] a lot
more attractive
and you know not as nasty yeah i mean i
think he even said that was one of the
um inspirations was a book that he had
read about countess bathory
also the um coleridge's poem
uh christabelle uh was also a big
influence
but yeah he was pretty open about his
influence too but then like i said bram
stoker was subsequently influenced
by this because this came out like much
earlier i tell you what back in the day
had i saw i didn't know about this movie
really until kind of recently
you know i'd heard of it but i never
watched it had i seen this
back when i was like 13 or 14 i'd have
[ __ ] been
all over this [ __ ] man well that's what
i'm saying though in the pre-internet
age you know what i mean where you
[ __ ] nudity could only really be seen
on [ __ ] screens
you couldn't get corny
yes i can't call this porn you think
maybe porn might break out at any moment
but it's a lot more higher class than
that you know what i mean
i was gonna say it's like a british
interpretation of what a russ meyer film
would be
but a russ meyer film really is kind of
like a blatant excuse to show
big ass titties well yeah i mean his
thing was just like
that trashy yeah but not in a bad way he
was like they were fun
he was just like unashamedly it was fun
and it was
definitely just softcore porn well yeah
that's all it was
uh they did have funny stories and [ __ ]
in them so
this is not really in the same league
it's like a very a lot more classier
than that
but it's still pretty hot it still has
some ex
there's some exploitation kind of [ __ ]
in it because you know there's scenes
where
uh you know carmilla is like is in the
tub
yeah you know with their big old boobs
and then like the other
girl comes in like all innocent and
everything she's like hey why don't you
try that dress on no you have to take
all your clothes off like that
look man [ __ ] britain knew how to
[ __ ]
get a lot of bang for the buck on a very
limited budget
yeah i think this costs like 160 000
pounds that's all
that's like nothing all right even back
in those days that was
yeah back in those days that was nothing
had really good sets really good
costumes good actors and
actresses the [ __ ] good script
there wasn't anything [ __ ] [ __ ] up
about the script
uh kind of an old-fashioned [ __ ] tale
that they're telling you they're not
really bullshitting around
they showed you a lot of [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] beheadings there's go some you
know
so there is some gore in it it felt a
bit like a horror movie but it also
felt kind of like a poor movie yeah it's
like a soft core board
it was like the best of both there
wasn't really any sex in it but you
thought it was gonna happen there was
nudity in it
um well there was some heavily implied
like especially
well especially where carmilla like
attempts because she
like moves into this one you know the
laura is the first girl
she dies and then carmilla moves on to
like the next family
and uh under a different name i think
she goes under carmilla that time it's
because the first time she's uh
you know maritza caller or whatever the
[ __ ] is this and so
she not only seduces the young wide-eyed
innocent girl and starts draining her
blood with the giant cat thing
but she also goes after the governess
who basically seems like she's pretty
into it
yeah she fell she's like yeah i'm down
yeah she's like
she just all she had to do she just kind
of looked at her like all [ __ ] gonna
do is just [ __ ] put that little
[ __ ] love that little
that little pin on her yeah yeah i'm
down i'm down
she was like all right because i don't
think there was then she like let her
into the other room yeah door closed
i don't i don't think there was any kind
of vampire magic involved
i think she was just up for it i kind of
got that impression too i mean they do
kind of say she's protecting her and
stuff from the men
yeah there's this big [ __ ]
man woman rivalry is pretty good like
carmilla's hanging out with this dude's
daughter you know she's the [ __ ]
blonde haired just through the roof
cutie disney character with the
she's just total innocence yeah her
dad's watching them he's like
something's going on here
yeah because they're coming down the
stairs going coming down together and
he's like
you can tell he's getting all suspicious
and [ __ ] and even the
even like the the governess got
suspicious what the [ __ ] is this
they're getting it on you can tell that
that's kind of but then he like shakes
it off oh no that would never happen
because this is the 1700s but hell yeah
that [ __ ] was happening
and then it gets into this big thing
where
there's two too many women in a room too
many hot women in the room
and the dudes have got to break up this
[ __ ] oyster fest
we got to have a sausage in here
somewhere all right we can't have this
we're no better
girls gotta [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then [ __ ] dude jumps on carmilla
just how you standing for this and she
starts putting the move on him you know
and he's like yeah this is which he's
like
yeah he's trying to get in that then she
kills his ass yeah
she's just using him it's like it's good
flick i liked it well yeah because she's
i mean like i said she does kill dudes
because she kills like the doctor at one
point everything to keep him from like
coming and finding out about like what's
going on
but she only she seems to only kill
dudes
to get them out of the way she doesn't
seem to have any sexual interest
in them but she does seem to have sexual
interest in
her female victims because she doesn't
kill them right away
this is what i felt about the movie you
take an old-school
gothic horror like something from you
know dracula or frankenstein you take
that
but then you put it in color you
modernize you know the way it shot a bit
yeah and then you amp it all the way up
the sex and violence and you amp that
all the way up
so far to the point to where if it went
any further it would leave the genre
yeah that's kind of what they did it's
kind of to me
these hammer films feel like the
ultimate expression of a [ __ ] 1930s
movie
is what they feel like to me yeah they
feel like maybe
they feel like this is what they should
have been doing back in the 30s this is
what they wanted to show you in in the
1930s but couldn't
that's what they kind of feel like they
don't feel they don't feel like a 70s
movie or an 80s movie or 90s but there's
nothing about
to me they always feel like a classic
universal
horror movie yeah but with smut but with
more smut
and more like what they wanted to do
back in the 20s and yeah
because they didn't want to do it but
they didn't just like they couldn't
you know away with it well they almost
didn't get away with this one like i
said
it was only the because there had been
like according to wikipedia
a few years before this came out there
was another movie i don't think it was a
horror movie but it was like a lesbian
themed movie or had a lesbian
relationship in it
and it was called the killing of sister
george and they actually ended up
cutting like five minutes out of that
which is like a significant
like amount of time just because we
can't have all this lesbian stuff in the
movie but you know when they
when they sent carmilla to the you know
sensors and i think this was even before
it was shot i think it was when it was
still in the
screenwriting the screenplay stage um
you know they said you can't do this
that and the other thing but then they
said why don't you read the original
story and all of it is in there
um and it's pretty blatant i mean
particularly for 1872.
so i do feel like that was the only
reason they got away with it because
they said it was a literary adaptation
and that was all in there
we talked about that we've mentioned
this many times in the show
the 17 really look people have this
weird
this weird idea that the past was
somehow prudish
uh-uh no not at all late 1700's as wild
as [ __ ]
there was there was a constant sexual
revolutions coming and going
you know well time is cyclical and it's
like people seem to forget because a
generation
you know you you kind of like forget
like what happened like
before you were born like before your
grandparents were born or whatever
so it does seem like you're kind of like
repeating [ __ ] over and over again
it used to be back in the old days
people were up to some wild [ __ ]
and the more rich you were the wilder
you were
because you had money
1700s 1800s go all the way back to the
[ __ ] roman era you know what i mean
they were people were [ __ ] wild
i think probably the only time where we
don't really
even some of the stuff that i read was
going on in the middle ages in europe
the church controlled europe at that
time but it turns out that
based on some of the stuff that i read
they didn't really control the average
person
the people in the churches were
complaining that these peasants just
kept having all these children out of
wedlock
and everybody was having sex with
everybody in the church couldn't stop it
well yeah what are you gonna do if
everybody's doing it you can't really
think of it you can't like police that
yeah how are you gonna punish peasants
yeah they're like our life already
you couldn't really punish them if you
locked them all up you'd have to if you
locked them up for that you had to lock
them all up where would you lock them up
and then how would the lord make any
money off this [ __ ] land
because they were tied to the land so
you really they just kept having
children and children and children they
were having children with people there
but really another thing is the concept
of marriage really wasn't that strong
in the peasant class people just kind of
lived together and had children and
swapped and you know i'm gonna i'll
leave this woman and get another one or
i'll have two or three women at once the
whole idea of
going to the church and getting married
was actually much later that was like
1500s
1600s that's when that [ __ ] became kind
of like
part of the civil law you know i mean
where
you got to get married yeah the church
really was money church wanted that
money
well yeah yeah that's why they do
everything that's why they did that okay
but back you know so there was a bunch
of wild [ __ ] happening all throughout
human history this whole
the idea of a prudish past is a myth
yeah and that's and that's a modern myth
uh although i don't know because the
ancient romans themselves
thought that they were more righteous
and pure in their past and that they had
declined into that i think they were
always like that
well the thing about it is that it's a
very human concept and i think this is
true across cultures that you always
think there was some
golden age in the past and that after
the good old days and things are like
degenerating
like that's a very very very common like
human conceit and it might just be
something that's hardwired
it was always degenerate pretty much if
you want that's what i mean
degenerate a lot of this [ __ ] they're
calling degenerate really just part of
human nature that's that way humans are
yeah they do all this [ __ ] they break
laws they [ __ ] [ __ ]
they do weird [ __ ] they kill each other
they die they get sick they die
they have a bunch of children they do
good [ __ ] it's just a mixture of good
and bad and it's just kind of
kind of constant yeah but like i said i
think that there's always been this kind
of like oh we need to go back to the
golden age we need to go back to
when things were awesome i'm like and
when was that never
never well sometimes you forget cool
things of the past
you know what i mean yeah that could
come back things make revivals all the
time
yeah you know i mean like if like for
instance we're getting off topic but
whatever they got rid of dueling yeah i
don't believe that
i believe that it's a human right to
duel if two guys
wanna [ __ ] fight and kill each other
all right they should be able to go to
lawyers and have an agreement for this
and have it so they have that [ __ ] that
you're gonna go because if nation states
can legally wage war on one another
why can't free citizens because a nation
of state will ask a free citizen you
have to join the army and go fight these
wars
you have to you're going to fight our
wars but no you can never fight your own
war
right all right right there that's
[ __ ] that sounds unconstitutional to
me
yeah i mean as long as everything is
above board and it's done like in a you
know
kind of a controlled right setting then
guys they said [ __ ]
we can't live we can't live on this same
planet together that's it
one of us has to go that's some [ __ ]
romeo said out of [ __ ] you know
either you
or me or both of us have to go either
you or me or both of us have to go
remember that
romeo [ __ ] uh this planet went after
tibble yeah yeah
it's like that's not big enough for both
of us yeah and the reason why the band
is dueling was because the young people
thought it was dumb really didn't have
anything it just changed over time
it's a dollar it's dumb don't do it they
were probably soy and [ __ ] and they
wanted to talk [ __ ] without any
repercussions
they didn't want anybody challenging
them so they could get away with talking
[ __ ]
but back in the good old days if you
talk [ __ ] to do a child you do a duel
now you could [ __ ] back down says no
i'm gonna do you then go see
you're a [ __ ] and they didn't want to
they didn't want to be bred at a [ __ ]
so they had to get rid of the dueling
but i think they put yeah they're like
uh we can't have duel and uh people will
call me a [ __ ]
sure as hell i ain't gonna go [ __ ] a
sword fight with that dude
so they need they need to bring back
doing if you're gonna defund police you
better bring back doodling
well like i said that's how they keep
that's how they kept each other in line
yeah everybody was a cop everybody's
their own guy everybody is their own cop
that's how it is in a lot of countries i
say whatever comes out of my mouth
that was a good one you like that one
yeah that was just well well that that
seems like a good like thing to put on a
t-shirt i'm just saying
whatever comes out that's going to be
the next 13th shirt i think that's just
going to say i say whatever comes out
right now yeah put your me on it with a
picture you want to go
with drunk yeah i got it with with no no
no i got
a smart ass look on my hook with a
[ __ ] tequila i say whatever comes out
of my mouth
yeah yeah that's how it should be but
yeah so uh we again we went wildly off
topic but yeah
vampire lovers first in the karnstein
trilogy they just added it on shutter
um and as far as i know twitter still
has twins of evil they might have just
added less for a vampire too so that
might be like all three of them but if
you wanted yeah
i don't think i've seen that if you want
to do i can't remember because i know
they just added a bunch of hammer movies
and they just added a bunch of
um roger corman's uh edgar allen poe
adaptations including mask of the red
devils
that's right twins the evil that's his
call yeah we did we did that one
that ought to be like th the fourth well
there was twins but there was four of
them because i was gonna say twins of
people
yeah the whole the whole two yeah two
two sets of twins the whole deal of that
one was about these
two blonde
twins cute as [ __ ] and bustiers with
their [ __ ] drowning yeah that was
kind of the whole theme of them
that was the thing they were just kind
of like look we have these two like
playboy bunny twins and we just want to
write a movie around them so we can put
them in corsets yeah they were playboy
bunnies weren't they
i think they were yeah or the equivalent
yeah and they look like they're about
18 19. i think they were they looked
real young
we actually looked up when we were
watching vampire lovers last night we
looked up how
old um ingrid pitt was she was 33 at the
time and she was 33 when this movie was
funny she looked like a well-preserved
40 to me at the time that's what i was
thinking
i think she's probably pushing yeah and
like not if it because she doesn't look
old
at all but she comes across i guess
because too
it helps that her character is like um
predatory yeah and she comes across like
a mrs robinson type of
i thought it was the same mattress that
played the sorceress in in in excalibur
no that was that was helen marin yeah
uh helen marin yeah helen mirren is
british and ingram pitt
is german okay okay they had kind of a
similar profile
similar kind of they do look kind of the
same i guess i never realized that but
yeah
i mean they look similar in their faces
and even the the governess the the
brunette
he was cute too yeah everybody in this
is beautiful well like i said that's
like a hamburger that's a hammer
that's a hair trademark thing that's
like why do you go watch hammer movies
you want to see like a bunch of hot
chicks
in corsets getting bit by vampires the
british understood
what theater what is that's why
hollywood is now sucks
you gotta have eye candy on there you
gotta have eye candy you gotta have good
looking people
and you gotta have [ __ ] a sexy story
that [ __ ]
excites you it makes you wonder what the
[ __ ] gonna happen next
and that's something that's like whose
boobs am i gonna see yeah what's that
it's gonna get cut off
yeah what's gonna happen and there and
and things have to be kind of
it has to have kind of an illicit tone
to it to
to it and hammer films the ones i've
seen mostly have kind of an
illicit feel to them but it's very high
quality i like it
and this was actually this was the last
hammer film that was partially funded by
american international pictures which
also did the roger corman movies as well
also i want to say too that there is
also a cute cat in this movie named
gustav
he was like a little fluffy like he's
big he's big fluffy
like gray cat he's like super adorable
so yeah thumbs up for gustav
all right so all right so we're gonna
end uh
this review of the vampire lovers
hopefully you guys enjoyed it we will
see you on the next one bye